[Musique]
je me souviens de gleneagles 2014 où
j'ai plaisir d'accueillir thierry
braillard secrétaire d'état aux sports
que j'avais d'invités qui a qui nous
avait dit oui à l'époque a tenu son
engagement et vous savez le club en c1
qui peut plus haut que parcours il
arrive sorte de voiture et en sortant de
voitures en temps cette clameur qui
venait des différents trop du parcours
on descend ensemble vers le 18 au moment
où une partie arrive et thierry
braillard me regarder ni c'est
magnifique c'est comme au foot sauf qui
vit à 18 stade thierry braillard a
toujours été à nos côtés découvrait vous
voyez le groupe sous un jour différent
et sa perception du monde du vin en
france et ailleurs est devenu tellement
différentes que ça nous a encore plus
rapprochés que les bons rapports que
nous avions déjà là aussi la magie de la
ryder cup à aubeterre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]